how many tourists are too many a hundred
snorklers on the water's surface and a
whale shark down below the world's
biggest fish comes to the flat coral
reef to eat it's one of the Maldives
main tourist attractions every year a
million vacationers come here in search
of paradise on and under the water coral
reefs are among the Earth's most
species-rich ecosystems and among the
most fragile what really gets to me is
the amount of life that's happening on
coral reefs and everything is there for
a specific function there are the fish
that are the doctors for instance and in
there the corals are the architects and
if you remove any of these rules and you
basically have a coral reef that's not
functioning
and what we need to do as humans to try
to sustain and maintain that balance
marine biologist Ameer Abdullah wants to
protect the reef corals are living
animals they grow extremely slowly
usually just three centimeters a year it
can take thousands of years for a reef
to develop but its destruction is Swift
climate change sewage overfishing and
tourists stepping on the coral the reefs
arch-enemy is man abdullah from the
international union for the conservation
of nature works together with fishermen
hotels and the government so that they
all profit from the reef and the
tourists who come to see it Abdullah's
goal is to unify their interests today
he's collecting data on a fishing boat
fish are crucial for the corals survival
fish eat the algae for example
like most of the reef fish this one
lands on the plate of tourists some
fishermen warn that stocks are already
declining taking too much here as a
resort there is a resort all resorts
people take so many fish everyday from
these reefs and lagoons to supply the
needs of every resort nature can only
help so much even so gassy money
continues to fish after all it is his
livelihood a lot of the fishes are
predators so the predator is basically
as we said are important for the the
reef because they keep a diversity high
is that so you know data collection
happening at the resorts and this is
something that we're hoping to change is
to try to understand how many of these
fish per species are being caught and is
that sustainable or not abdullah passes
is data under the government so
officials can regulate fish quotas and
preserve the reef
one country one problem but more than
2,000 different islands how can
environmental protection even function
here Abdullah is counting on direct
cooperation with hotels and resorts
Hotels working with Abdullah's project
wanted type of tourism that's beneficial
to the reef the German hotel manager of
rate D Beach is a trailblazer her team
wants to guard and protect the islands
reef a marine biologist from IUCN will
help first of all of course we're acting
in our own interest the reef the island
is a privilege for us and we naturally
have to see that we protect it
the tourists come to dive but if there's
nothing here anymore then they won't
come over the next few years marine
biologist Barbara qotsa will monitor the
condition of the reef just off the
island and anyone interested can also
receive information about the underwater
world a coral skeleton might be a nice
souvenir for many snorklers but like
living coral even dead coral is
important for the ecosystem
that's probably 20% of tourists or even
fewer know that corals are animals very
few know that corals are so fragile and
why they need protection as a longtime
diver I've become more careful in recent
years but every new bit of information
increases awareness that as a diver you
have to be more careful with the
environment good
where are the unique coral species and
where is the reef endangered qotsa and
Abdullah are creating maps and
management plans they hope the project
will make the reef less susceptible even
to influences that they themselves can't
control the coral reefs are exactly like
human beings in many ways if they are
healthy and they're not stressed by
local impacts and they'll be able to
resist the impacts of climate change the
global impacts of climate change the
protection project where the ancient
ecosystem is scheduled to last for four
years but if it's successful its effect
will be felt for decades to come